este fue el momento en el que yannick
jadot aseguró un puesto en la carrera
por la presidencia de francia al superar
a su rival y ganar la nominación de los
verdes
quiero agradecerles mucho a ustedes
porque gracias a ustedes soy el
candidato de los barrios para las
elecciones presidenciales
120 mil personas se registraron para
votar en línea
la campaña de hallado tiene un enfoque
orientado a la solución con políticas
medioambientales
el hombre de 54 años fue elegido
diputado al parlamento europeo en 2009 y
es el único miembro de los verdes con un
nombre reconocido a nivel nacional en
francia y algo débil bando ya pero hasta
un plomo desde crisis hago un llamado
para que los verdes se unan para ir más
allá y así podamos llegar hasta el
palacio de elíseo también a la asamblea
nacional para una nueva ejecución del
poder para todos los ciudadanos si ha
llegado el momento de cambiarlo todo y
es la calidad de nuestro nuevo proyecto
de sociedad ecológica donde vamos a
conseguirlo
en 2016 yannick jadot ganó las
elecciones primarias de los verdes pero
luego respaldo al candidato del partido
socialista esta vez los dos principales
partidos de la izquierda francesa temen
perder votos en favor de los verdes si
ven el partido obtuvo una serie de
éxitos en las elecciones municipales del
año pasado aún no ha logrado un impacto
importante en la escena nacional
[Aplausos]